like it does seem like a really baffling
choice because they have to know it's
already hard enough to avoid spoilers as
it is and i feel like this is a film
that has been so highly talked about
worldwide this broke records for trailer
release on youtube this should be a
movie that's celebrated globally on the
same day
and also so these guys don't have to
have the movie spoiled for them
[Music]
what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today so we got some real
spider-man no way home news to talk
about first things first there might
have been an official poster that has
actually been spotted gotta talk about
that because fans have been wanting an
official poster for quite some time am i
right john absolutely so right i'm
always right
secondly spider-man no way home has been
delayed in japan and in the philippines
and this is a really big deal taking it
kind of personally even though i'm going
to get access to it here in the states
quite passionate about that story so
we'll talk about the poster then we'll
talk about this petition of don't delay
no way home ph that means philippines
benoit right so here we go so we got
this poster here um i already saw this
poster oh did you see it uh only in
small thumbnail form and i was like i
gotta save my
full reaction but uh this is sure a
poster so yeah i i saw this poster and
basically the long story short is that
in australia someone spotted this on a
bus and as we all know there were some
theaters that had fan made posters up in
their halls making it look like those
were the real posters but they've been
desperate to promote the movie so
because they didn't have an official
poster they've just been using fan maids
so the question's been coming up is that
is this fan made i'm having a hard time
believing it's fan made only because to
print it out on a bus like that it's not
the same thing as printing it out and
swap it out with this one thing in this
in your hall of movie posters everywhere
to put it out on a bus more work for
installation on there than just swapping
it out in a frame you know yeah and not
to mention it's going to be traveling
all over town and if somebody from you
know sony happened to see that it's a
lot more likely that they would be up in
arms than you know one random theater
having a fan made poster yeah see john
you get it that's where you're the guy
right marketing now this poster though
what i find fascinating about this if it
is indeed legit which i'm likely to
believe it is real is that for so long
we've been wanting an official poster we
got a trailer before we got a poster a
lot of us were speculating that the
reason they probably delayed the posters
because they're waiting for the second
trailer to come out that way we could
have a poster that's probably more
telling more revealing has some major
things on it
they had to hold off on showing until
they had a second trailer out but then
you see this poster and if it is real
it's cool
but there's nothing really super special
about it it's a shot we're all familiar
with it's the iron spider moment from
the trailer you got the doc ock arms
like if this was the first image we ever
got
that would be like insane but after
everything we got you're kind of just
like i could delay this or so
if this is if this is indeed it maybe
when we get a second trailer we'll still
get a new poster one that is more
revealing maybe one that has like the
sinister six laid out on it if they do
show toby and andrew in the trailer or
tease them maybe we get like them in the
shadows and their spider suits back
there or something like that for a first
poster yeah it gets the job done you got
the upside down city talking about the
doctor strange world but at the same
time like why don't you just release
this earlier yeah i know that's the
hodgepodge of little literal images we
saw in the trailer so it seems like it
would have been perfect to accompany
that first trait unless they're going to
trick us and throw out a bunch of other
things later that have hidden details
but this looks pretty straightforward it
looks straight forward it's better than
the far from home posters sure
what do you guys think do you think it's
real and if it is real do you guys like
it you're thoroughly satisfied leave
your thoughts down below now on to this
next story yesterday i examined all
these messages because uh as you guys
know i'm full white john 100 filipino
pinoy pride over here and because of his
filipino roots people were messaging me
and being like greg you gotta get this
message to chill stand up for john he
needs to see spider-man the same day as
everyone else yes my pinoy pride started
kicking in when i was like what do you
mean this is getting delayed in the
philippines and then akka-san was like
bitching about it being late in japan
i'm like yeah whatever
but the philippines i'm so sorry for
your loss guys no no it sucks i think
everywhere this movie should be released
on same day now i was looking into it
and i decided to put out a tweet to ask
some people like what's going on here
why is it delayed in the philippines
obviously you could chalk it up to like
covet protocols some theaters around the
world like some people are not getting
venom until like now or december some
theaters are
only just starting to reopen and some
won a big launch in 2022 at the
beginning of the year that i i do get of
course i do i know it's like business
marketing strategies you got to play
with different markets yadda yadda but
this is spiderman no way hope this isn't
any other movie
short of end game yeah so when i asked
like what's going on some were saying
that like yes that the theaters are not
really gonna start opening it up until
like january 2022 the most common
consensus that i was seeing in terms of
feedback that people were giving me on
twitter i'm gonna quote here arthur
fleck uh no voice in dusky one every
december there's a film festival in the
philippines that runs like two to three
weeks long that's why hollywood
blockbusters often move to next year or
not shown at all i'm still pissed i
wasn't able to watch aquaman in theaters
back in 2018 and was also in december
and looking further into this yeah
that's true there is some big film
festival that goes on for two to three
weeks so oftentimes they'll push things
to january some are saying that they
want to have like a big launch for their
new releases in january specifically and
i was like well
how january to a couple weeks later
makes a major difference for a film like
spider-man no way home but it doesn't
really make much of a big difference for
i i think the theaters you know like of
course i'm not one who's gonna go
against safety protocols and health
guidelines i'm just having a hard time
imagining why what would be the a major
difference between january 7th and
december 17th that you had to like wait
that specific time frame and you're
making this decision in november yeah
absolutely especially if you're going to
have theaters which is reported at least
some of the theaters in the philippines
would be opening i think november 10th
with dunes so it seems as though they
would have the opportunity and if you're
gonna be open at all it seems like you
would be leaving money on the table not
to put no way home out as soon as
humanly possible you know and the reason
why i'm thinking this movie out of any
of them should be released same days
because it's spider-man no way home
obviously this is a movie that has had
many
leaks that are so
vastly conflicting it's gonna have major
major spoilers look how secretive the
marketing is we just spent the first
three minutes of this video talking
about how they haven't released a poster
yet this movie is has insane secrecy to
it and that's why people are like trying
to scoop and try to figure stuff out
bottom line is is that the people in
japan and philippines they're not going
to be able to avoid spoilers
successfully no one in the world will be
it's like yeah just stay off the
internet for like three weeks you know
that's that's a lot to ask for people
don't watch tv don't talk to your
friends don't go outside don't go to the
movies you know like don't go anywhere
like let's say they want to keep the
andrew and toby thing secret and then
the movie comes out and they start
putting it in trailers like with
avengers end game it wasn't too long
after end game came out that they
started showing the finale battle
and avengers assemble in the actual
marketing promos that was the marketing
directly it's already hard enough to
avoid spoilers as it is and i feel like
this is a film that has been so highly
talked about worldwide this broke
records for trailer release on youtube
this should be a movie that celebrated
globally on the same day
and also so these guys don't have to
have the movie spoiled for them i know
we sometimes talk about leaks i know we
sometimes talk about scoops i also
respect if you have zero interest in
learning about any of that i totally
admire not wanting anything to be
spoiled for you there's gonna be a lot
of people get [ __ ] swell for them
without them even trying
absolutely just out in public i'm sure
it's gonna be the topic of conversation
because you know that even the people
there who can't see it are probably
gonna have access to the info and some
folks love to spoil things or love to
just get the details and talk right away
like it does seem like a really baffling
choice because they have to know marvel
and everybody else seems to care a lot
about the secrecy and not spoiling
things and spoilers are more rampant
than ever it seems like a lot of this is
about marketing and about money i know
you take it personally with your
filipino in japanese no
i know so there's a petition here the
hashtag don't delay no way home ph and
there is a petition that's been put up
that
on
change.org
getting a lot of signatures lately i'm
going to put it in the description box
and i'm going to link it in the pin
comment if you just want to show your
support all i require is a simple
signature it literally took me like 15
seconds last night to sign this petition
i'd encourage you to do it too because
if you're a spider-man fan i feel like a
big part of what would spider-man want
think about it like that what would
spider-man want he'd want all of them
to forget who he is apparently
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell columbia
pictures sony i'm asking you kindly on
behalf of all fans not just the people
in the philippines and in japan i know
that it doesn't feel like a likely
scenario but it would be a baller
respectable awesome move if you could
just make an exception
around it or delay it in the us
till the 7th and see how that goes make
an exception here i know you guys have
the the the protocol that you usually
abide by around this time of the year
but let's try to make an exception for
these guys
the video's over now
[Music]